now chinese state media says the u.s.
has been throwing groundless accusations
over the origins of covert 19 US
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo has said
there's significant evidence it
originated in a Chinese lab while the
intelligence community continues to do
its work they should continue to do that
and verify so that we are certain I can
tell you that there is a significant
amount of evidence that this came from
that laboratory in one but the best
experts so far seem to think it was
man-made I have no reason to disbelieve
that at this point as the scientific
consensus was not man-made or
genetically modified that's right I I
agree with that yeah I've say I've seen
their analysis I've seen the summary
that you saw that was released publicly
I have no reason to doubt that that is
accurate okay so just to be clear you do
not think it was man-made or genetically
modified I've seen what the Intelligence
Committee has said I have no reason to
believe that they've got it wrong well
Katrina you is in Beijing with more on
the reaction there to Pompeii as
comments there has been a escalating war
of words between the US and China in
recent months and this latest state
media editorial is only adding fuel to
that fire so it was in the Global Times
which is a chinese state media newspaper
and it's published both in English and
Mandarin and both versions really had
searing words attacking Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo in particular they
called him a liar
saying that he quote is engaging in
filthy behavior to mislead the public
and that he's lost his moral compass
they've also accused Michael Pompeo of
really only being interested in getting
Donald Trump reelected in the next
elections in November and and in Storer
keying anti-chinese hatred in order to
do this now this is in response to the
comments we heard earlier of Mike Pompeo
saying that there's significant evidence
that curve in 1908 it in a Chinese lab
in the Rue Han Institute of virology and
Beijing has flat-out denied this it's
also denied that it's engaging in any
cover-up or just information campaign
and this editorial is really demanding
that Mike Pompeo and his colleagues
really produce this evidence that they
say they say that they have and they
just said that he's really just engaging
according to state media in a
bluff in a big Bluff and really just
continuing this anti China's smear
campaign in order to divert attention
from Washington's mishandling of the
crisis back home let's cross over to the
White House and our correspondent there
Kimberley halket in Washington DC and
Kimberly the war of words as we can see
between the US and China is not only
hotting up but President Trump really
seems to be on a mission to castigate
Beijing any response to China's
statement well the response has echoed a
report by the Department of Homeland
Security that essentially accuses China
of downplaying the threat of kovat 19 in
essentially not allowing the world time
to prepare adequately as a result now
there's no question that the secretary
of states is putting forward this there
is enormous evidence to point the finger
towards China in terms of securing the
realities of kovat 19 but at the same
time none of this evidence has been put
forward so the United States is also
challenging China to put forward the
evidence to the contrary and of course
we haven't seen that either and the
reason this is getting traction in the
United States in terms of the finger
pointing towards China by the US
president is the fact that this is known
to be a government which is
authoritarian which is not transparent
and as a result this is becoming a
really an election issue and Donald
Trump is looking for someone to blame
there's no question about it this is an
election year he has been criticized
repeatedly by his political opponents
the Democratic Party for ignoring the
intelligence not acting quickly enough
on the intelligence but the reason that
the president's finger-pointing is
getting some traction is the fact that
the reality is that people are hurting
in the United States initially before
the onset of Kovach 19 there was
historically low unemployment a very
strong economy all of that has been
obliterated so people are suffering and
they looking for someone to blame as
well as the president who's trying to
blame some
for the fact that he may not be
reelected as a result of this pandemic
so the president is finger-pointing but
there are many Americans who are echoing
those sentiments because they too are
suffering well let's just expand on
evidence and economy because everybody
wants to see evidence but that evidence
can be defined as intelligence in the US
and therefore classified and so the
public are left with just hearing an
argument and perhaps a a more political
argument about economic independence for
the US and that's what's really
convenient for both sides not just the
United States but also China when the
argument is that this has classified
this proof or this evidence came out of
a classified setting we can't share this
and we can't make this public because
this would risk national security it
becomes very easy to manipulate and so
so far we've not seen a real push for
that evidence because there is that
understanding but I expect that as time
goes on as we get closer and closer to
the u.s. election that that will change
now already we've seen in some
battleground states here in the United
States Michigan being one of them that
there is a now an ad being run that is
criticizing the US president for his
action in the early days with regard to
protecting the United States that he
ignored or downplayed the intelligence
that there wasn't a swift enough action
to close the borders given the fact that
even though the president points out
that he put in place a blocking of
travelers from China and late January
that 40,000 people still did come back
to the United States now these were in
most cases returning Americans but again
the concern is that not enough was done
to stop the threat early enough so this
is something that is getting some play
in the United States and will continue
to do so but you're absolutely right
when it comes to intelligence it's very
easy to say we can't share this with you
trust us and really it will come down to
a referendum on whether Americans
believe the president or not come
election day in November indeed for the
update can be healthy there are White
House correspondent thank you